camera expense most of last week trying
to stop you care at all costs denouncing
him as a federal listings now people
wrong man for Britain he got the job as
Cameron knew he would
and now the Prime Minister has to sort
of start stacking up to this guy meet
Isabel tell us about the phone call that
we had to make last night well you made
a phone call yesterday afternoon in
which he congratulated Yonker on getting
a job they'd been trying to stop him
from getting and did you have to make
this phone call or release I don't know
whether is something that you have to do
but of a protocol when he had to make it
politically because he spent so long
attacking Yunker that he has to now
start building bridges with the guy in
order to have any chance of getting
anything from a renegotiation and down
the street were very key to emphasize
that you talked about advancing British
interests in Europe and addressing some
of their problems now whether addressing
British problems is a bit like saying
you'll address address something that
you're actually just dispatching is
another matter
yeah and Jim's how much of this strategy
Jim it was deliberate I mean the I don't
think they intended to get him to the
mess they ended up with you curb it but
once they got there camera obviously
failure right let's just press ahead he
must also have thought but I've got to
work with it's going for years but still
I'm going to go hammer at Thomas yes it
was I think he wants to send a message
to the other European units that when he
said something he means it
so we suppose we negotiations all the
pre placement medication I mean there
two things to watch an attack series one
is doesn't lemarchal I'm can have done
the dirty on David Cameron and then turn
back when the assurances she gave him
about stopping income does she now put
together over the next few months a kind
of series of measures designed to
address Britain's concerns and secondly
is the person who succeeds Herman Van
Rompuy so the the new president of the
European Council who's gonna have to
broker the deal between Cameron the
other 27 EU leaders over the
renegotiation is that someone Brit
friendly dines we are quite clear but
they want the hella foreign Schmidt
but Danish PM may see her as a
pragmatist and they also mean the fact
that Denmark is are gonna fellow EU euro
out yes this is mrs. K
yes this is Neil Kinnock daughter-in-law
and so the question now is does Cameron
get a candidate he wants in in all
people even more important job for the
renegotiation and does mark will put
together a series of measures yeah
George Altman flew to Berlin last week
to see Wolfgang Tyler his opposite
number
Chandra's cannot stand to look we can't
lose Britain Germany would do whatever
it takes to keep person in I made the
big water thing happen we'll notice that
what he's learned from this euchre
experience is that Merkel can give me
assurance and then that could be trumped
by her domestic political needs so
Cameron is never gonna be oh is never
gonna quite be the same again mr. Ian
Cameron Merkel he's always gonna have it
back of his mind now is she gonna - is
she gonna turn on six buttons won't have
coalition partners kick up or when the
German tabloids kick up physical we what
we have seen is a very dramatic change
in tone towards the EU I mean we or the
Cameron Racine that was almost too
recognizable from the one who was
shafted by Sarkozy a couple of years ago
so Jenni Cameron's going to keep his
fists flying now from now until
renegotiation if he gets the chance
well he's got to and he's also got to
have a few successes now that he's
failed on Yom Kippur lot of Tories do
measure him by these victories in Europe
and he's actually set that out for them
to do as well as he talks about the EU
budget cart which he conveniently
forgets was instigated by rebellion in
the Collin Commons he talks about the
veto which also wasn't quite the success
he claims it was he needs now to not
chop a few successes to show that he has
lots of about in Europe and I suppose
some kind of compensation package as
James talked about
we'd help him on that and the other
grace from ash at the moment is between
Ed Miliband and John Curtis and Curtis
who we have a spectator of tentative
admirer we Myron him all the more now
that he seems to be calling out some of
the Flavio policies and Ed Miliband's
agenda significant because he's the guy
who's in charge of Ed Miliband's policy
review he was recorded at this compass
meeting 10 days ago and deploring the
way and the way the IPPR of course you
know huge two years it took it was
condensed he was saying into an
headline-grabbing thing about being
means young people on benefits but James
the litigants is this he doesn't do we
have we learned now that Cronus is at
loggerheads with it Miliband and that
his boss is going to get policies he
isn't going to like well what this story
has done its ported V open mr. massive
tension which we well whenever I got the
job he appointed various and
intellectuals electron products to do
things for them it's a feat big I'm John
brothers was gonna charge of the policy
review I'm an intellectual Renaissance
believe on what that is running up again
is the realities of the election
campaign that Doug metallic snarl
inspector living will want to run John
Kronus wants is can a beautiful whole
redefinition of estate Englishness
everything the left reimagine socialism
for the 21st century dunsack moment
spent a little more give us some point
since we can sell on the doorstep and
that don't create too big a target for
the Tories to attack that's what this
was about
okay so Isabel where does this go next
will Curtis have to say how sorry he is
or can we just take it for granted this
there's a fault line has been exposed
within in Labour Party I think it will
be interesting to see what the next
policies that come out on how that's
well maybe he'll get some opportunity to
as James says do something kind of
visionary that they're all quite fully
understand but isn't time running out
for vision I mean the Tories dropped the
big society on us variety leaves in the
campaign yet if you're going to have a
big vision shouldn't we've had it been
now he's also already done quite a lot
of visionary stuff and this is the kind
of tension in the labour team is do you
have this kind of pragmatic campaign
where you aim for the largest party
rather than thinking you're going to go
for a majority and trying to reteach the
whole of the British electorate to think
laborious or do you think y'all gonna do
that Marian quote and I said you've
campaign aperture and your guilt me in
prose I'm drunk drunk Chronos wants to
kind of campaign in rhyming couplets
what does that mean though exalted to
campaign a bullet points right and who's
going to win this battle it I mean it
did all the way to describe it it's as
if when John Curtis comes out with his
great big ideas he's going to be told no
sorry won't work and the doorstep so
publish it as a think-tank document I've
ever seen I think we know
I've been in if Gladys gets computer
than 30 percent of his ideas through I
think there will be a massive explosion
I one of the problems for labor
it's that up to up in the last six
months ago the family knew the date of
general action work to neighbors paper
now it works against them because
normally what you do is in opposition is
you dream John Krogman about the rim dr.
Norris and says look I'm terribly sorry
he didn't count in the country in
October so we we just can't have to
write them up fest so now terribly sorry
about that
Norman out do everything you can but but
I mean the government are about to cut
and run you can't do that anymore and so
Cronus will say no we've got plenty of
time to have an argument about what we
couldn't manifest it and I want what
I've been working on for the last three
years in that and you see the explosion
won't form like that take any thoughts I
mean I mean the big explosion it's gonna
be stuck like this all not secretly
taped but on the record I mean John
promises interview of the New Statesman
on so he was a prop real crime pain you
know did crime leadership topped runs
and all this I think that I mean leave I
think if if he's intellectual prospectus
is rejected I think he's gonna make
quite clear the disillusionment than
that is cause I think there's also
already across the shadow cabinet being
a greater willingness on the part of
people in the shoddy cabinets its brief
against one other I think you've just
seen more and more and more
that's why do they think they're going
to lose them once I well I think there's
been lots of different fractions are
some who won't like John Kronus to
advance their own view of how to fight
an election there are some who don't
care so much about this election and
what to think about the next election
when they could be glorious leader and
that there is some who would disagree
with the wake up it's only cleaning
cases and there's also folk on the third
or fourth school which is look we could
remarkably they they say in private look
we could win this election it could be
that the fact that you keep releasing
into a Tory vote the left that live
don't effectors let's not blow this
let's just play this safe let's get over
the line for the night I to win but I
keep doing things like this to
themselves oh there's an interesting
question in that the moment with these
labor divisions are being clearer in
recent weeks and they happen for a long
time does that begin to have any effect
on the polls well they will still have a
reasonable lead which
actually teach back up a little bit
after your village